conservatives are coming for no fault
divorce from Jezebel they say after the
fall of Roe right-wing media have been
ratcheting up their rhetoric against no
fault divorce expect policy to follow
the reason why this story is from August
we're talking about now I didn't catch
this when it came out but they referred
to our good friend Ian Crossland as a
conservative commentator so let me show
you first a little bit what they say in
the beginning I love this because they
talk about us where where are they going
to do it
an authoritarian liberal yeah you were
right about that yeah
they mentioned uh here we go in it uh
there's a popular conservative
influencer Tim Poole oh really I'm
conservative now in a segment on the
show I love that one because they say it
a lot but conservatives are like yeah
Temple is not conservative temple in a
segment on the show was Delight that was
delightfully titled no fault divorce has
destroyed men's confidence and marriage
men don't want to get married anymore
yeah that's true there are studies that
show that we're not just like screaming
into the wind we're like reading things
are going wow look at that according to
pool you know guys can't you at least
cite the thing I'm reading and not me
I'm not like fabricating things on the
wall they say we have no fault divorce
laws to blame for the rise of prenuptial
agreements
yes
duh okay moving on
which allegedly plays men at risk of
being robbed by gold digging thieving
Jezebels oh name drop their own website
willfully ignoring how the court system
is a long history of re-traumatizing and
destroying the lives of rape and
domestic violence victims no we know
full well that's called fault right when
a guy commits a crime against his wife
now there's fault you can get a divorce
congratulations you understand what no
fault means
the best part of the article they write
in the same episode on Poole's show
conservative commentator Ian Crossland
adds quote we live in this culture where
no fault divorce is the law of the land
dot dot dot if young folks know they're
in an environment where divorce is not
an option I firmly believe they're going
to be more careful about who they choose
to marry also a very dry fact statement
I mean it's a dry analysis Ian didn't
come out and say arrest all of the women
who try to get divorces he said if
people can't divorce they'll probably be
more careful about it yeah but I didn't
say that if I did that was a misspeak I
said that if people can't get a uh no
fault divorce if people can't divorce
wait what does it say if uh if young
first of all I don't use the word folks
that's Obama speak and I know I don't
use that word so they're misquoting me
they took it
we got to pull that up because they
didn't link to the story either so I
don't know what the referencing
something like two months ago but it
wasn't that if people can't get a
divorce it's if people can't get get at
no fault divorce then they're going to
be much more choosy about getting
marriage I don't I don't ever advocate
for people not being able to get
divorced that's complete Insanity if a
guy beats his wife she should leave him
and make him pay yeah
so they actually did link to the segment
and it was with uh oh Dr Chloe
Carmichael was on the show at the time
this from a few months ago I'm not going
to play through it and try and find the
point where where Ian says the word
folks or whatever but I just love that
this is how the media operates they just
they lie they they falsely frame things
yeah I might I might have used those
words but referencing that if they can't
easily get a divorce so I'm not saying
that they're misquoting me I'd have to
reference the data here's here's the
point I want to make thank you uh
Jezebel for giving us the opportunity to
bring this subject back up if no fault
divorce is the law
then marriage does not exist
dude you can marry a woman and she can
leave you the next day and take half
your money literally well that's a bit
extreme but she can't typically they
would annul not divorce what's the
difference annulment means it didn't
happen so if you get married to someone
and the next day try to dissolve the
marriage they would probably file an
annulment and not allow a divorce
divorce but but there are circumstances
where it could be like six months to a
year and all of a sudden now it's like
they are entitled to half of your
belongings so marriage is a contract you
know between two people the state
certifies it to enforce the contract and
it used to be in the past someone would
be like I don't I don't like her she's
annoying and I want to be with her I'm
like yeah well too bad you s you entered
into a contract with this person you
have to now abide by this so they create
no fault divorce and now it's basically
dating
it's like okay there's no marriage
anymore it used to be that you would
date you would not there'd be no binding
contract or anything and if you didn't
like it you'd walk away
then you'd say you know what I think
this is working I'm willing to enter
into a lifetime contract with you
enforced by the law and they'd say okay
and you do it no fault divorce means
marriage doesn't exist anymore for all
intents and purposes except for the
purpose of stealing money from you know
one one party or the other
yeah it's an opt-in business contract
where you split your finances but the
fact that one of the partners can cancel
the contract and then take half of your
wealth is complete Insanity Luke if me
and you started a company well me so it
is like I said me and you started a
company it made a million dollars and is
that what the young kids are calling it
yeah well you know we'll just call it
you want to start a company Luke will
you start a company with me
and then if you decided to leave the
company I mean what do you I think you
don't get any the company still stands
and I have the rest I still own he would
own it I mean and this a better argument
would be I entered to a contract with
Luke that I'll provide lumber for him in
exchange for uh coal and then one day
Luke delivers coal and then I say I'm
I'm terminating the contract and then
looks like what you can't do that where
you're supposed to give me the lumber no
I had no fault contract is call sex is
that what the roof
no I'm just saying like in a marriage
you're basically saying we're going to
build a life together whatever that may
mean it means maybe the wife works maybe
the husband works maybe they both work
but the reason why the assets are pulled
together is that they're forming a
family unit they're gonna have kids and
this is going to help a woman who gets
pregnant and things like that no fault
divorce means that you can enter into a
contract share all your resources and
then someone can leave so perhaps a
better way to explain it is you know you
merge companies and it's like you let's
say you have a podcasting company and a
major media conglomerate worth tens of
billions of dollars says we're going to
do a merger with you and then you go
okay but it's a no fault merger I can
leave and take half half of Warner
Brothers like that's so weird and then
you can also have kids with get married
to a woman have kids and then she can
just be like one day be like man I did
some Ayahuasca I had a change of heart
I'm Gonna Leave You take the kid and
make you pay me money yep you're like
what in the hell is going on what how is
this even like a romantic or like
righteous thing there's no marriage
there there's no marriage there at this
point with no fault divorce marriage is
basically a tax bracket that's it it's
like oh we're married now so we get a
tax benefit but anyone can leave any
time so there's no real contract there's
no point in doing it what's the purpose
only that you can give your spouse money
untaxed that's it it's just a business
basically a loophole almost at this
point well child custody is where a lot
comes into all these things of course as
well and then that unfortunately becomes
in a lot of cases The Leverage that's
used in the divorce unfortunately that
that becomes as much of more leverage
and oftentimes than even the money
like who gets the kid yeah and how would
that work like a a person would say you
can have the house if I can have the kid
kind of thing or vice versa I I don't
think that that's what they would say in
court but it's like a bargaining chip
like the yes kids being used as a
bargaining chip and divorce has been
going on probably since the beginning of
divorce but but it used to be that if
you try to get a divorce a court would
be like no
it's like I want to get a divorce
because you know he uh I mean there were
there were serious cases where women
were being abused but they couldn't
prove it and the courts would be like no
divorce nice try you can't do it that's
a problem the solution isn't no fault
divorce that's insane
because now you now you're going to get
fatherlessness women who are getting
abortions because they can't afford the
kids instead of having a father who's
around with the fatherlessness
fatherlessness needs leads to crime and
poverty and now we're seeing the ripple
effect of this where politicians like
Stacey Abrams are like the solution to
women who can't afford a kid is to kill
the kid and that's insane the solution
used to be someone had to earn to
provide for that kid now it's just like
well that's not going to happen so to
kill it with fault divorce before what
1969 or whenever it got introduced and
it was like the Bolsheviks actually the
Russian Bolsheviks are the ones who kind
of created the idea of that you could
just divorce with no fault um but before
that was it that a guy would beat his
wife and she couldn't prove it so she
couldn't leave him kind of thing and
that was a problem so they were like we
got to liberate these women I don't know
if that was the main reason why they
decided to enact no fault divorce but
there often you'd go to court and be
like we want to get a divorce and the
judge would be like nope I you know
sentence you to marriage counseling
so you they would not divorce and then
the argument was that women were being
beaten raped and traumatized and it led
to suicides and no fault divorce
resulted in a lowering of the suicide
rate among many married women
yeah don't get married that's the crazy
thing it's like you have a problem with
marriage don't get married but they do
and then they're like hey it's not
working out for me let's destroy the
institution instead of just realizing we
made a mistake like I don't want to tell
you don't get married if you want to get
married get married but I don't want to
get married right now because of no
fault divorce
straight up I mean I'm just being honest
I don't want to get married and then
have the woman just be like yeah you're
acting like a jerk I'm out give me half
of your everything you've ever earned
I'm like what are you kidding me no way
yeah and fortunately I'm with a woman
that feels the same way and I think
there are a lot of people out there
Russell Brand was married to Katy Perry
right yeah I think the story was that
when they got divorced he was entitled
to a ton of money and he was like I
don't want it yeah and I mean like
Russell Brand is already rich so he's
like I don't want to deal with I don't
care about that yeah but I still respect
that
for sure but I mean you see this is the
problem when you have guys who are like
you know what I'm a man and I have money
so I don't need to take half of your
stuff meanwhile you look at every other
case the overall majority it's the woman
being like I get your stuff this is true
look at Mackenzie Bezos amazing she got
what did she she got half right I think
she get half of it wasn't 50 billion or
something that's crazy I'm not married
and they got divorced yeah yeah she
married some guy did the guy take half
of her 50 billion when they got divorced
is that record I don't know if he took
there's no way yeah because because that
they weren't married long enough yeah
and it was after the finances had been
gained she was married to Bezos prior
while he was building the wealth yeah
but with a marriage you get if they
divorce don't you get all the money back
to birth like everything you've ever
been worth if you were from yeah but but
it's not so unless you sign a screen up
you had assets coming into a marriage
and so those get taken to it into
account as well and States it also
varies state by state you know what the
rules are when it comes to that also it
can be everything you've ever earned and
owned like if you own a house and then
you get married and then a couple years
later you get divorced yeah you're out
that's the funniest thing the Trope
about divorce is the husband always gets
booted from the house and then I watched
breaking bad and I was like oh there you
go you know because I'm breaking bad
she's like get out you're like no it's
my house and the cops are like it's his
house have a nice day and she was like
oh no but that it's crazy that these are
the tropes that you know you watch The
Simpsons and the the van houtens or
whatever get divorced and the and the
you know Mouse's dad just leaves and he
goes and lives in like a bachelor pad
and I'm like why it's his house you know
all of these things like
it's just you grow up watching that
stuff and you're like what's the point
of marriage I gotta tell you man
feminism seems to have been one of the
worst possible things for women in not
in the terms of like you know they got
their independence they get their jobs
and here's this one's for you Young
Turks and feminist websites you can take
this one because I know you're going to
want to spin this one out of context but
uh the issue is now guys can bang
whoever they want whenever they want
with no strings attached that's a not a
benefit to women no when when regardless
of what your mentality is let's just
break it down to simple probabilities
and numbers
women when they get pregnant they either
have to have an abortion to get rid of
it or they have to have a child whereas
if a guy goes to a party and there's a
bunch of you know people doing crazy
stuff and he hooks up with a random
chick because we're in this hookup
culture and she doesn't know who he is
and she gets pregnant dude has nothing
to worry about that's a problem the
problem for is for the woman the benefit
is for the men guys can go and party and
hook up and never have to think twice
about it but women do so I don't know
how this hookup culture benefited women
I guess but there was an article in the
New York Post today that was titled I'm
dating so many men I need an Excel
spreadsheet to organize my love life and
reading that that story kind of was was
a little depressing uh understanding our
our current landscape but this is where
we're at you know and I I think we have
to you know talk about these things uh
from from an open-minded way you know
different people have their different
experiences they need to go through them
in order to see that they were wrong but
I think also as a society we should be
considering the long-term kind of
consequences for them and having those
kind of conversations and debates whoa
this is big someone just superintendents
right now Ian was right about folks
Jezebel misquoted Sheamus as Ian the
time stamp is
10303 really can we uh 103 oh we only
have the clip I don't have the the full
episode so I don't know where they would
actually that would actually be in the
episode but it was Sheamus who said it
and they claimed it was Ian who said it
that is
that is interesting illegal for them to
do that it's not illegal it's a civil
tort meaning uh oh it's the clips are
actually broken down arranged marriage
loans I miss that guy by the way I love
you Seamus where are you at uh it means
if you so that's a false statement
effect that's that's actually serious on
Jezebel's part it's been up for months
we've now discovered that the question
now is Damages okay damages is girl that
you wrote it come on the show Kylie
Chung
talk to me about this that's not how it
works
have you lost money or have you been
damaged by them attributing Sheamus to
you
I mean people are making fun of you you
need corrective marketing now and that's
I I understand the process no but this
honestly I'd rather just communicate
with Kylie about it all right well well
in public corrective marketing we may
have to do for the show and I mean this
so when it comes to defamation damages
in the form of corrective marketing
means if if you know one of the aspects
of this show is we have you in here for
a reason Ian is not your typical
conservative commentator quite the
opposite and we don't actually know what
your background is you're kind of a
weird dude and that works some people
don't like you some people really like
you some people say you were one some
people say you roll 20s well that's kind
of the point we don't want to make a
cookie cutter show so having opinions
that we can't predict or having weird
arguments sometimes makes it more
interesting than your average
one-of-the-mill show if they're now
lying to people and saying that Ian is a
conservative commentator it is actually
hurting the point of having you on the
show that means we have to do corrective
marketing I gotta buy a Times Square
billboard a view that's really expensive
it's gonna cost Jezebel and and
Jezebel's gonna have to have to pay for
that because they're claiming you're a
conservative when the point I mean
Luke's not a concern conservative Luke
said and Anarchist libertarian type I'm
weird middle of the road Ian is weird
all over the place and then we have a
free frequently we get libertarian and
conservative guests but if they're going
to make false statement of statements of
fact about one of our co-hosts Sheamus
was a temporary co-host he's a coach on
the show for quite quite a bit but he's
not a staff member here he's just a
recurring guest and friend of ours he's
not a part of the he's not he's not like
a core staffer at the company so I'm I'm
sorry like this this might end up being
very very expensive we got we gotta look
at how many views they got how many
shares it got then we got to do
corrective marketing and they're going
to pay for it who super chatted that by
the way because thank you so much for
that that was uh tangent tangent they
pointed this out really a lot I don't
know I'm gonna try and play this because
maybe it's here this is going to give me
like
uh no I don't know if this is It's the
time Stampy gave us in the full episode
we don't have that we only have the clip
so it's gonna be hard to find yeah this
is the episode with Chloe Carmichael the
Ping trip famously took out of context
on purpose to make a killer uh satire
video oh it might be this let me let me
play it you know it's funny because we
live in this culture where no fault
divorce is the law of the land and
people will say things like well look
how often marriage ends in divorce how
could you ever be in favor of social
structures which disincentivize that or
would you know dissuade people from
getting divorced but I think what people
often miss is if young folks know
they're in an environment where divorce
is not an option I firmly believe
they're going to be more careful about
who they choose to marry and I think
also people can be more careful about
their decision making in general when it
comes to sexuality a lot of people will
start sleeping with someone and as
you've mentioned that releases oxytocin
and other hormones that Bond you and
there are a lot of couples that end up
together because they're sexually
engaging with one another and they're
bonding but they're not actual really
really good for each other and then at
some point in the marriage when the
novelty of that person wears off they
get divorced so I think well there it is
it was Sheamus Jezebel posted fake news
a false statement of fact about who said
what see here's the thing Sheamus is a
Catholic conservative he is it's so he
has those opinions not Ian Crossland no
definitely oh man that's uh that that's
that's bad for the reputation of the
show I'm gonna have to uh man you know
we have to employ some corrective
marketing here so you go after obviously
the company well I'm wondering Kylie
Chung the author or do you the company
Jezebel like who's on the hook for that
both of them yeah they're both yeah so
Jezebel's supposed to have a standard
here where I mean this is a this is a
Brazen fall statement of fact they're
not going to be able to hide behind
opinion on this one they outright said
Ian Crossland's ads quote and not only
that the quote from Sheamus was very
long he made a lot of interesting points
and uh it's it's interesting that they
cut out a core element of what he said
which is the race of oxyto person the uh
you know that people are engaging in
hookup culture they cut all that out
attributed to Ian Crossland who's not a
conservative commentator and now they've
got a very very direct false statement
effect that's not an opinion statement
right they said Ian Crossland did this
thing you did not do it that's false oh
well
we're gonna have to I'm going to call my
lawyers after this you know I didn't
even catch that thank you to tangent for
pointing out it was Sheamus who said
that 965 million dollars right now
or else I'm paying his legal fees yeah
965 million the reality is not too much
that's not too much we'll do something
about it because you are in a position
to do something a lot of the little guys
out there that have these kinds of
things happen to them in these media
organizations all the time they don't
really have the ability to fight back
you know it felt very like I was being
molested when I read that the comment
that I didn't make attributed to me I
was like this is like a really creepy
feeling but I had the confidence knowing
I was coming on the show tonight to talk
about it if I didn't have a show like
this that would have been devastating
because I I even started to question did
I say it yeah what's wrong with you have
no way to fight back
so here's here's what'll likely happen
um corrective marketing is Damages and
in all seriousness I'm gonna have to
talk with you know our marketing people
and a lawyer about it to see how we deal
with this because you know I'm uh it's
out it's out there people are talking
about it yeah um I tweeted about it
calling it absurd and laughable and so
we'll take a look at it but the reality
of what likely will happen is they will
issue a correction and that ends it
if we have to do corrective marketing we
can then escalate and say no no you got
to pay damages because we got to pay for
marketing because of what you said if
they're going to correct it at least say
that I'm a wild hippie right if you're
gonna if you're gonna categorize me as
something geez it mentions EMT in the
corrections you know it depends on how
many hits it got we'll have to we'll
have to the corrective marketing will
involve Research into the reach that
this did so there's probably a bunch of
YouTubers who talked about it and then
started repeating the lie that Ian
Crossland said these things he never
said so hey man it's one thing if they
said in our opinion Ian Crossland you
know is a fascist or a conservative you
can't sue over that's in a protected
opinion but this is an outright false
statement of fact that's like very very
obvious so it's it's Reckless disregard
for the truth in that capacity that was
Sheamus thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
Tim IRL podcast and there's a massive
library to check out so again go to
timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there